>> THIS IS THE FIRST DINNER
TOGETHER WE'VE HAD AS A FAMILY
WE'VE HAD IN A LONG TIME.
LET'S TRY TO SURVIVE IT.
FIRST LET'S SAY GRACE.
JACKIE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
ANY?
>> I SHOULD HAVE TRIED TO
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU VOTED THE
CRAZY WAY THAT YOU DID.
>> AND I SHOULD HAVE UNDERSTOOD
THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU WANT THE
GOVERNMENT TO GIVE EVERYBODY
FREE HEALTH CARE BECAUSE YOU ARE
A GOOD-HEARTED PERSON WHO CAN'T
DO SIMPLE MATH.
>> Laura: AT [LAUGHS]
AS WE MENTIONED AT THE TOP OF
THE SHOW, THE "ROSEANNE" REBOOT
GENERATED 18 MILLION LAST NIGHT,
FINDING WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN
HOLLYWOOD MAKES PROGRAMMING THAT
IS NOT CONDESCENDING.
JOIN JOINING ME TO ANALYZE THIS,
IN OUR "SEEN AND UNSEEN"